news daily from science mission  scientists show that ferritin the major  iron storage protein was strongly  associated with cerebral spinal fluid  apolipoprotein e devils and was elevated  by the Alzheimer risk allele fo you for  also baseline CSF ferritin levels were  negatively associated with the cognitive  performance over seven years next using  two in vitro models scientists in cell  reports show that physical presence of  synaptic contacts between neurons  facilitate tau pathology propagation  next scientists show that activated gut  interstitial lymphocyte iel provide a  first line of defense against infection  by upregulation of antiviral interferon  responsive genes that helps regrowth of  healthy aec for more details visit as a  www science mission calm and science  mission facebook page thanks for  watching